DEBBIE NEWHOUSE: So it's my
pleasure to introduce to you
Dr. Todd Rose.
He is the director of the Mind
Brain and Education Program
at the Harvard Graduate
School of Business.
He is also the head
of the Laboratory
for the Science of the
Individual, which Harvard
founded because of the concepts
that he Todd and his associates
have developed.
He's also the
co-founder of the Center
for Individual opportunity.
So I hope this afternoon's
talk will be eye opening
and interesting to you on a
personal or professional level.
So please join me in
welcoming Dr. Todd Rose.
[APPLAUSE]
TODD ROSE: Thanks.
Great, thanks for having me.
Full disclosure-- I had this
terrifying dream last night
that I was up here.
And then the first
thing Debbie asked so
how many golf balls fit into
a-- and I was like wait.
I'm not asking for a job.
I'm just here to give a talk.
And they said, no,
no, no, everyone
that gives a talk at Google
has to answer these questions
first.
And I literally
woke up drenched.
So I'm assuming that's not the
case, because I would fail.
And then you wouldn't
care what I had to say.
So I am here just to give a
talk about my new book called
"The End of Average"
that touches on some
of the scientific
work that we're
doing around trying
to understand people
as individuals in
a scientific way
and thinking about
the implications
that these insights have for
our institutions in society
all the way from education
to the workplace.
And my goal is just to
frame two big things for you
at a high tops level that the
book explores in greater depth.
One is this idea that seems
almost like a bumper sticker.
But it has pretty deep
scientific meaning,
which is there's
literally no such thing
as an average person.
And yet we built our whole
society around this idea
that there is and that we can
reference ourselves against it.
And then I want to just touch
on if you believe me there
is no such thing
as average, and you
can't use that as a
reference point, how would we
think about individuals
in a systematic way
and introduce you to these three
principles of individuality
that we use in my
lab and other labs
to investigate people
and understand them.
So just as a
starting point, I am
going to tell you this story.
The first time
that I encountered
scientifically the failure
of averages was back in 2002.
I was working at Mass General
Hospital doing brain imaging.
And I was actually still
a doctoral student.
So I was gung ho.
And we're thinking
we're really smart.
And this is how
we used to do it.
And some people still do it.
So if you were all
in my study, we
would take you, bring you
in, put you into a scanner,
give you a task,
scan your brain,
and then this thing that we do
literally algorithmically you
just combine all of your brain
patterns into an average brain.
And then we publish the results.
And this is just the
way we've done it.
And we do it in neuroscience.
But we do it in all other
fields of social science
with the assumption
that averages
would have to
represent some people
or else that would be kind
of silly to be using them.
So here I am in 2002
doing brain imaging.
And there's this paper
comes out by my colleague
Mike Miller, who's now
at UC Santa Barbara.
And he's studying what was
pretty straightforward, which
is how your brain
retrieves memory.
And I say straightforward
because we've got
so many studies on this topic.
And we know the areas of the
brain that retrieve memory.
In fact, if you had
asked me back then what
we know for sure,
I would have said,
we know these brain areas
that retrieve memory.
So he does this study.
And he does the method
that I just described.
And he gets this result. Here's
a picture of the average brain.
It looks just like all
the other studies that
have studied memory retrieval.
But he said he was in
those scanner sessions
just kind of watching
students run the sessions.
And he happened to notice
one subject whose brain
pattern seemed a little off.
And so he remembered
it being an anomaly.
And he thought it didn't
look like the average.
So he did this very
simple question
that's kind of surprising
that people hadn't really
asked before.
He thought, what if
I go back and look
at the individual
brains in my study?
How many of them are roughly
close to this average brain?
So here's what he found.
He goes back and looks.
Here's a couple of
samples from his study.
These were all people who
did the task successfully,
by the way.
Here's one subject's brain.
Here's another one, another one.
I just used three to
give you a sense for it.
You can go on and
on, because what
he found was not a
single brain looks
anything like the average.
So he gets worried.
So rather than
publish it, it's like,
what if you made a mistake?
That's not a good way
to start your career.
So he kind of shelves
it for a while.
But then a few months
later it's nagging him.
So he brings the same subjects
back roughly six months later,
puts them in the same scanner,
gives them the same task,
gets the same
result. The average
still represents nobody.
But what was really
interesting is the way
the individual's brain was
doing the task remained
really stable.
It was these patterns of
individuality that mattered.
Later on, they would figure out
that those patterns would group
around different strategies
that the brain is using
to recall memory-- more of a
visual anchor, spatial anchor--
verbal kind of stuff.
So this pretty much
rocked all of us.
Wait a minute.
What are we doing then?
And it really changed
a lot about how
we think about brains.
But what's interesting is
over the last decade or so,
it's not just been
about brains anymore.
In every field where
we have the data
and we can look at individuals,
we found the exact same thing.
So for example, there's no
such thing as an average cell.
There's no such thing
as an average genome.
as average cancer.
There's no such thing
as average performance--
everywhere we've looked.
Now, this goes all the way
up to behavior and learning.
So when we look at
students, we find
there's no average student.
There's no average employee.
That's a fact.
But here's the problem-- if you
take something like education,
we literally built our
existing industrial education
system on the idea of
an average student.
And if you think about for a
second, when we buy textbooks,
we literally at the
governmental level
say you need to design them
to be age appropriate, which
actually just means for
the average of that age.
And you ever think when
we give kids tests,
they're standardized
norm referenced,
it's about how they
perform compared
to a hypothetical
average student.
And we fix the
amount of time kids
have to learn how long they can
take a test all in reference
to averages.
Right?
So the problem is, again
scientifically, we realized,
OK, there's no average.
What do we do?
And we know now that, by
the way, I was going to say,
when we think about
these systems,
people think, well, why would
we have ever built an education
system on average?
But it was built in
the industrial age
by people who were absolutely
obsessed with averages,
because they worked
fantastically well managing
factories when you could
treat each individual employee
as a cog, right?
Where you really
want to descale them,
and they could be
interchangeable parts.
But we're stuck now
in modern society
with a system of education not
producing the talent we need.
And we have a hard time
hiring the right people
and assessing their performance.
So we're really kind of doing
some soul searching around we
want something different.
We want more personalized
kinds of education.
So most of my work nowadays
is in personalized learning.
Like, what does
that actually mean?
How do you do it at scale?
And the challenge is that
if this was 10 years ago,
we actually didn't really
know how to do that.
But I think what's exciting
and what I wrote the book
for is that today we do.
We actually have a
science not surprisingly
called the science
of the individual.
And it is interdisciplinary.
And it's basically
revolutionizing every field
that it touches.
So almost every advance
made in medicine
that's on a personal
level has come
from these new kind of methods
around studying individuality
instead of average patterns.
In terms of human behavior,
and learning, and performance,
it comes down to the
science offers us
these three kind of principles
for thinking about you.
So if I am not going to
understand you based on average
or how far you deviate from
it, like, how would I know you?
So the rest of the
talk, I just want
to touch on these
three principles
and give you some concrete
examples about how
to think about them.
So the first one is
called jaggedness.
Its simplest form is this-- all
human characteristics that we
care about are multi-dimensional
and cannot be reduced
to a single score ever.
And yet, this is all we do
whether its body size, or IQ,
and stuff like that.
So let me tell you the
first time we realized
this jaggedness principle.
It was actually
back in the 1950s.
It was the first
time that we realized
there was no such thing
as an average body.
And in the '50s, the
United States Air Force
had this really
serious problem, which
is we had just gotten
these jet powered planes.
We went from propellers to jets
that go the speed of sound.
And they had enormous
performance problems.
So these pilots who used to
be fantastic were now failing.
And we didn't even
have enough pilots.
So they were trying to figure
out what's the problem.
So the generals for a while--
they actually blamed everyone
they could possibly blame.
They thought it was the pilots.
They literally said,
well, this generation
doesn't have the right stuff.
They're not as good as
the World War II aces.
And it turned out that the old
World War II aces were having
the same kind of problems.
So then they blamed
flight instructors.
You're teaching them wrong.
And that turned
out not to be true.
What it came down
to was the cockpit.
And let me just give you
the short version of it,
which is since the Civil
War, the guiding design
philosophy for the
military had been
if you want to design
something like a cockpit,
you need one cockpit that
fits most people, right.
And you're going to fit
every one but one cockpit
to fit the most people.
So the thinking
was this-- if you
designed a cockpit for an
average-sized pilot, that
would be your best choice.
So what they would do is they'd
take 10 dimensions of size.
They would calculate the
average for each dimension.
And then they would expect
you to build the cockpit
around that.
And it almost seems
like intuitively true
that this would be a way to
do it that would cover most
people.
So they're busy doing this.
But one guy-- this guy
named Gilbert Daniels.
He's one of my favorite people.
He's newly hired at
Wright-Patterson Air Force
Base, who's been
charged to conduct
this massive study of
pilots to calculate a better
average, right?
4,000 pilots--
he's 23 years old.
He's never been in
the military before.
But he's brought in
because he majored
in physical anthropology.
So he knew how to study bodies.
And they said, OK, just
get us a better average.
But he harbored this
feeling that maybe average
was the problem.
And so he convinced
the generals to let him
do a little study with data.
So he basically asked
a simple question.
Out of these 4,000
pilots, which at the time,
were white males who were
picked because they were
close to average,
how many of them
were actually average on
these 10 dimensions of size?
And the general said,
look, it's a waste of time.
We know like most of them
will be except for he
runs the analysis.
And he finds out zero.
Not a single pilot was actually
average on these 10 dimensions
of size.
In fact, less than
4% of them were
average on three
dimensions of size.
So they realized really
quickly this was a design flaw.
They built cockpits that
literally fit nobody.
And to their
everlasting credit, you
would think for
such a hierarchical,
conservative institution it
may be difficult to get change.
It took him less than a
year once they convinced
the general-- showed
them the data that this
was the problem
that they actually
mandated you could never design
cockpits on average again.
You couldn't design
flight suits on average.
You need to design
flexibly for a range.
So what's interesting
is, like, we've
known this about body
size for a long time.
It's convenient to say
you're a size medium.
But there really
isn't a size medium.
If there was some
standard medium,
you wouldn't need
a dressing room.
You'd just grab it.
But it turns out
in this science,
when we've started looking, it's
not just about physical size.
Every human characteristic
that we've looked at
shows the same kind
of there's no average.
But often when I tell the
story about the pilots,
they think like, why
isn't there an average?
There's just really short
people, and big people,
and there's a big
missing middle.
But in fact, let me show you
what Gilbert Daniels found
that gives you the clue
to why there's no average.
These are two pilots--
not the pictures,
those are just for fun.
But these are actual
body dimensions from two
of the pilots.
And this is what Daniels found.
Every single one of them
had this kind of jaggedness
to them.
He's be on the high
end on some things,
in the middle on
others, and then you'd
be on the low end
on some things.
Every single pilot showed
this kind of jagged profile.
And so it's like,
well, obviously,
if you designed something
right down the middle,
it's going to be a bad
fit for most people.
But like I said,
as we've expanded
this looking at jaggedness
to different characteristics
of human beings, we've
seen the same exact thing.
So we could do this on character
and other kind of things.
But let's just talk
about intelligence.
So these are two
real sets of scores
from two women on the most
widely used adult intelligence
scale.
Right?
Now, they converge on a single
score that's identical, 103.
So if we don't care to know
them, it's easy if we say,
well, they're the
same intelligence.
We can from
one-dimensionally rank them.
Except for if we actually want
to know something about them,
if we really want to
nurture their potential,
then it really matters
that one of them
is better at spatial things and
poor at verbal and vice versa.
So this jaggedness
principle has lots
of implications for designs
of environments, right?
We still design on average.
We have lots of problems there.
But often, this can
feel kind of abstract.
So I would give you one
personal example of where
this mattered quite a bit.
So on my way to
graduate school, I
had to take the GRE,
which is-- and I'm
terrible at standardized
assessments.
So I thought, OK, I'm
going to study like crazy.
On Saturdays, you
take the practice.
And you have a
mentor and whatever.
And this guy that was
teaching the class,
he scored perfectly on
the GRE, as you would
expect if you're teaching it.
And so they have those
three-- back when I took it,
there was verbal,
quantitative, and then
they had this analytical
reasoning where it was like,
it still give me shudders,
like, Farmer John
has four rows of things, and
corn can't be next to potatoes.
Then they give you
all these conditions.
And they ask you
a question like,
if potatoes are in row
3, what's next to it?
And you're like, I have no idea.
So I'm practicing
all these exams.
And I'm doing fine in verbal.
And in the quantitative, I
cannot for the life of me get
these Farmer John questions.
And after 10 weeks,
I have not cracked
beyond the 13th percentile.
And I start thinking,
OK, I've got good grades.
I've worked really hard.
But I'm not going
to graduate school.
No one's accepting me with a
13th percentile score on this.
So the mentor of our
class had actually
taught us a strategy for
the Farmer John thing, which
was very verbal-- in your head.
So I, lucky as can be, two
weeks before the actual exam,
I happened to be at my
parents' home studying,
because I actually was married
with two kids at the time.
And I couldn't get a
quiet time in the house.
And I'm so frustrated that
I'm just like, I give up.
And my dad happens to be walking
into the house at the time.
He said, what's the matter?
So he's an engineer.
And he said look, this is a
degrees of freedom problem.
And I'm like, I have no idea
you're talking about, right?
He says, but you're
doing it wrong.
You have terrible
working memory.
But there's a way to
visualize the task.
And if you get it out of
your head and onto paper,
you'll be better at it.
So he gives me this
very simple strategy.
I'm like, there's no
way this can be true.
But it works on
the practice test.
And two weeks later, I scored
by far my highest score was
on the analytical reasoning.
So I went to Harvard
for my doctorate.
And of course, then people
that see the score are like,
Todd's very analytical.
Sure.
We'll go with that.
But sometimes,
even just matching
of strategies against
your own jaggedness
matters so much, because there's
always multiple strategies
to accomplish an outcome.
OK, so we start with jaggedness.
Again, the book dives
in deeper in terms
of what this means
for how we hire,
how we assess performance,
stuff like that.
The second principle is
the context principle.
And simply stated,
it is that it is
meaningless to talk
about behavior or talent
independent of the immediate
environment in which you're
behaving and performing.
And that sounds simple except
for if you think about it,
we talk about
things like traits,
as if you have something
that's the essence of who
you are that doesn't
really vary that
much in different contexts.
It's just a stable
part of who you are.
And that's been the
way we've thought
about things in psychology
for a really long time.
But that's coming undone now.
And I'll give you
two examples of this
that are some of my
two favorite kind
of studies in recent science.
So how many of you are familiar
with the marshmallow task.
This is great.
It doesn't matter where I go.
Most people have
never heard about it.
It's like the study for
our generation of the pop
psychology stuff.
So for those of
you who don't know,
here's the short
version-- simple version.
You bring in some toddlers.
It's supposed to be about
delayed gratification
and self-control.
You bring in some toddlers.
You put them in a room.
Some adult says, hey,
here's a marshmallow
or we'll do a variation with
candy-- whatever you like.
But we'll stick
with marshmallows.
Say, OK, here's one marshmallow.
You can eat that now.
Or I'm going to leave the room.
And if you don't touch-- you
don't eat the marshmallow.
When I come back, you can
have two of them, or three,
or whatever number you want to
do until the kid says I really
want that big pile, right?
So then what we do is the
adult leaves the room.
And they'll leave
for up to 15 minutes.
And you just wait.
And then you put a
camera on the kid.
And you just wait to
see how long will they
wait before they just
eat the marshmallow.
And it's really cute.
If you go on YouTube,
there's all kinds
of really cute videos of kids.
One kid thinks he's clever.
He licks it and puts
it back and thinks
I haven't eaten it, which I
think he deserves a gold star.
That's so clever, because
technically, he didn't eat it.
But we actually think
literally how long
you wait is a measure
of self control.
And we love this study.
And I think it's a cool study.
But we have correlated it
with all kinds of things.
So on average, how long you
wait as a toddler predicts
things like how well you'll
do in school all the way
through high school.
Even it correlates with
socioeconomic status
and happiness in adult life.
We've even brought
the same toddlers that
were in the very first
study 40 years ago back
and put them in the scanner to
look at correlates of the brain
to see, hey, look
this part of the brain
is different in people
who were better at it.
We're obsessed with it.
But we've definitely
thought of it as a trait.
You have some self control.
Some people have more of it than
others except for my colleague
Celeste Kidd, who is at the
University of Rochester,
did what I think is the best
study on the marshmallow task
yet.
And it deserves really
wide recognition.
Before she was a scientist, she
worked in a homeless shelter
for families.
And when she first heard about
the results of the marshmallow
test, she got really
worried, because she
was thinking the kids in
this homeless shelter-- they
would definitely eat the
marshmallow like immediately.
But not necessarily because
they have impulse problems,
but because if
they didn't eat it,
some big kid or even an adult
would take it from them.
So rather than just worrying,
she did this great study.
And here's what she did.
She does the normal
marshmallow task.
She has two groups of toddlers.
But before they do
the marshmallow task,
the kids get to
do an art project.
They get a little cup that
they get to decorate and split
the kids into two groups.
Both groups are told, hey,
here's some busted up crayons.
You can decorate this cup.
Or if you wait, I'm
going to go out.
And we've got a new
art set with stickers
and all kinds of cool stuff.
If you don't start coloring
yet, when I come back,
you can have this new art set.
And you can use that.
So then in one group, the adult
comes back with the art set.
In the other group, the adult
comes back and says, ah,
I'm really sorry we
didn't have the art set.
Then they give them
the marshmallow study.
So here's what she found.
In the group, where the
adult keeps their word,
these kids are rock
stars of self-control.
As a group, they
waited 12 minutes.
And most all of them
waited the full 15 minutes.
They said to stop the study,
because these kids probably
wait for a really long time.
In the group, where the
adult didn't keep their word,
the group waited for
about three minutes.
And most all of them,
except for I think one,
ate the marshmallows
in the first minute.
So what's really
interesting about that
is when you start taking
context seriously,
it challenges even
what is self-control.
We're so used to thinking
it's something you have.
But this is something about
trust in your environment.
And it opens up whole new
ways to think about how
we help these kids, right?
We're so quick to say let's do
some training on self-control.
Everybody is like, how about
we work on the environment
a little bit?
So when we talk about
context, one thing
that we often here-- people feel
like, OK that's probably true.
But that seems
really complicated.
And it seems like it
would really make things
complex and hard to understand.
And maybe sometimes
that is true.
But what we find is more often
than not, when you take context
seriously, it tends to simplify.
And I would give you
this one example.
This is my absolute
favorite study
that I've seen in a long time.
So how many of you know
the stepping reflex?
OK, so here's what
it looks like.
When little babies
are born, they
have this really cool--
they look like they can
walk if you hold them upright.
They have a reflex.
They move their feet.
So I got married really
young, like 19, which is not
good life advice for anyone.
But it worked for me.
And I had my son Austin.
And I'm not kidding.
So he's born.
And I'm playing around
with him at home.
And suddenly, he
starts doing that.
And I was so excited, I
thought he was amazing.
He's walking already.
So I called my
mom who's a nurse.
And I was like, mom, mom.
Austin's walking.
She's like, what?
He's like one-month-old.
How is that-- and I said,
no, look, and I told her.
She said, oh, look, Todd,
that's called the step reflex.
Don't worry.
It will go away.
And sure enough, about
two months of age,
it goes away only to come back
right before he learned to walk
nine months like everyone else.
So here's this puzzle of why a
reflex would disappear confused
not just me, but
lots of scientists
for a really long
time, because there's
no other reflex that does that.
Why would it go away?
So for decades and decades,
scientists puzzled over this.
And they bring kids in.
And they use this
method of averages
to try to figure out
correlations between things.
Why would it go away?
So the best story
we had for it was
that it was brain maturation.
In the 1960s, we
realized, we think,
oh, your frontal
areas of your brain
mature, and they
suppressed the reflex,
and then it comes back later
under voluntary control--
really complicated explanation.
But we thought we'd nailed it.
We thought we knew that
problem was solved.
It gets into
pediatric textbooks.
And now we know.
If you're step reflex doesn't
go away about two months of age,
you might have brain issues.
Your brain might be
developmentally delayed.
So we start sending kids in
for remediation based on you're
still stepping.
So we thought we had
it nailed until one
of the pioneers of
this new science--
a woman who has since passed
away named Esther Thelen,
she said, this
doesn't seem right.
It seems a little too cute--
this simple story-- brain
maturation.
So she decides she's going to
do this very-- kids in context
looking at individuals
instead of averages.
She takes little
kids-- little babies.
She put them on treadmills.
She puts them in water.
She does all these things
to vary the context
to try to figure
out what's going on.
And she figures it out.
It turns out it had nothing
at all to do with the brain.
It was purely about
chubby thighs.
It turns out around
two months of age,
little infants get a burst of
subcutaneous fat on the thighs.
And they just can't
lift their legs anymore
when you hold them up like this.
That's it.
You put them in water, and
the buoyancy, they come back.
You put weights on kids.
And it goes away.
She figured out a precise
mathematical relationship
between body size
and fat on the legs.
She could predict
exactly when a kid's step
reflex would go away.
So here we had this
really complicated story
about brain maturation
that we're sending kids
for remediation based
off of when it turns out
to have nothing to do with
that just by taking context
seriously.
So the last one that I
just want to touch on.
And I think it's a
really important one.
It's the pathways principle.
And simply stated is that
individuals differ naturally
in the pace and
sequence that they'll
follow toward any
outcome that you want.
And as a result, there are
always multiple pathways
to success, always.
It doesn't matter if we're
talking about learning
to walk or career progression.
There's always more
than one pathway.
The problem is when
you use averages,
there can only ever be one
pathway-- the average one.
And so we've structured school.
We've structured the way we
think about human development--
workplace environments, as if
there's this normative path.
And that basically all you can
vary is how fast you go on it.
And as a society, we
definitely have a preference.
We think fast means smart.
And I have to say like, if
you asked me a few years ago,
I definitely thought
fast meant smart.
And we still do.
If I said, your kid
is a quick study,
you'd definitely think I'm
saying they're smart, right?
So on average, it turns
out speed and ability
are correlated.
But what we've found recently,
and I was really surprised
by this to be honest, that
when we look at individuals,
there actually
isn't a relationship
between speed and ability.
It turns out the kid that
takes a little longer to learn
something is just as likely
to master it as someone
who rushes through it.
But there's a problem
here because in education
in particular, we actually
built the system-- have you ever
wondered like, for example,
who decided how long you get
to take a standardized test?
It's actually the average of
the representative sample.
That's what determines
how long you get.
And this was baked into our
education system from day one
by a guy named Edward
Thorndyke, who's
the father of
educational psychology.
And he was a lover of all
things standardization.
So he had a view of
intelligence that
was it was how fast your
brain makes connections.
And he thought globally,
like some brains are
just better than other brains.
And so when they were
trying to figure out
how much time to give people
to learn and make assessments,
he figured, if you pegged
it to the average, sure,
the fast kids might
be bored a little bit.
But at least you're
not wasting time,
because kids that
would need more time
wouldn't be smart enough
to take advantage of it.
So we've still carried that
legacy even into the workplace.
Like there's a
certain amount of time
you get to do tasks with the
assumption that fast is smart.
So I think one of the most
interesting things that's
happened-- you guys are familiar
with Khan Academy and stuff
like this, right?
Self-paced learning
environments where we just
stop fixing the time
and let people vary.
So what we're finding here
is just incredible actually.
This is real data that
was all way back to 1980s
from Benjamin Bloom.
But Sal Khan is finding
the exact same things.
In fact, his TED talk
is fantastic about this.
So these are just
five kids where
they're learning-- I think
this was actually algebra.
And you see what they had was
this was that when the class
exam was supposed to be.
So they give them a kind of
arbitrary time to give an exam.
And you can see these
kids kind of rank out.
This kid at the bottom,
he's definitely not
doing very well, right?
32%.
Like, if we just stop
there and say, OK, this
is what you know about
this topic, right?
But because the study gave more
time for some self pace, what
they found was that
actually, in fact,
this kid ended up with the
best score in the class.
And this has been
replicated over
and over again
the second we stop
fixing the amount of
time kids have to learn.
It turns out that there's
just not that relationship
between pace and ability.
In the book, I go into greater
detail on different pathways
things in everything from
cancer to actually workplace
environments.
But I want to end,
because there is
a reason I wrote the book,
which is as a scientist,
I had this naive belief.
We know that averages don't
work to understand individuals.
We know we have
a better science.
We know we have principles
of individuality that
give us a better foundation.
So I sort of thought being
right would be good enough.
We've got the data.
So it's just a matter of time.
But I decided to write the
book when I read this story.
So it's not enough to be right.
So it turns out that the
Air Force wasn't actually
the first group to
figure out there
was no such thing as
average body size.
Seven years before that, the
head of American Gynecological
Association decided
to create a statue
of the normal average
American woman.
Dickinson is his name.
So he gets data from 18,000
women on a whole bunch
of different dimensions.
And he crafts the sculpture.
And he calls her Norma.
And that's the sculpture.
If you want to come see
one of the versions of it,
Harvard Medical School
has a copy of it.
This caught on like
wildfire with the public.
It was crazy.
She was shipped around
to different talk shows.
It was an obsession.
And the obsession peaks when
they decide to have a contest
to find Norma.
So in the newspaper, they
start having this thing--
they tell women send us your
measurements on these nine
dimensions of size.
And you could win $100 war bond.
And they're so convinced.
It was kind of gimmicky, right?
But they were so
convinced there'd
be thousands of
women who were Norma
that they had these elaborate
explanations for what to do
and when there are
these 1,000 women.
How do you decide who
gets the war bond?
And the YMCA was supposed
to be the arbiter
of the final measurements
and everything.
So they go through
this whole contest.
And it turns out
they named a winner.
Her name was Martha Skidmore.
And she was actually
only average on three
of the dimensions.
It turns out just
like the Air Force,
they found there was
literally no such thing
as an average female body size.
And these were women who
thought they were average enough
to be willing to send
their measurements in.
So here's the thing--
when they found out
this information
instead of realizing
that the whole idea of an
average body was nonsensical,
the head of the study, Bruno
Gephardt, goes to the public
in the newspaper and says, look,
I know what the problem is.
American women are
profoundly unfit.
And he said, the answer
to that is more exercise.
And they instituted PE programs
where young high school
girls were asked to measure
their dimensions against Norma.
And they were given PE
exercises to match that.
So for me, this
story was important
because I realized they had the
same information that the Air
Force had.
And yet the interpretation
was completely different.
So I wrote the book
because I think
we live in this really
interesting time where
we can collect unprecedented
amounts of data on individuals.
And especially in
an area where I'm
at in personalized
learning, we just
assume that if we collect
more data, we're on our way
to understanding individuals
and that we'll somehow
use it in a way that
does really good things.
But if the Norma
story is any guide,
that's just not a guarantee.
The interpretation
really matters.
And we're still
stuck as a society
with this mindset of averages.
We're so used to seeing
ourselves as a type
or how far we deviate
from the average,
that defines almost everything
about how we see ourselves--
how we see our kids, how
we see our colleagues.
And I'm completely
convinced that unless we
get past that mindset and
think about individuality,
we're not going to
be able to exploit
the data and the technologies
that give us a chance
to have better learning
environments for all better
hiring practices, better
performance reviews.
So that's the point of the book.
Try to have a conversation with
the general public about how
we see ourselves as people
and what that means for how
we build social institutions.
So thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: If averages
are not useful,
which I think you've made a
really compelling case there,
what do we use in its place?
Percentiles?
TODD ROSE: Yeah,
it's a good question.
So I think it's important
to clarify too-- averages
are useful sometimes.
So even the very idea
of the average man,
which I lay out in my book,
like the origin of that.
One guy came up with this
average man in the early 1800s.
It gave rise to insurance
for the first time.
So averages are really
useful, and even percentiles,
when what you care about is
the population-- the group.
But the second you want to know
something about one person,
they actually fail to predict.
So from the science
standpoint, we actually
have a strong view that
actually understanding is never
comparative, right?
You don't really know much by
comparing it to something else.
So what we try to
do is take these
what we call these
principles of individuality
and look for
individual patterns.
And then we can group
from that, right?
We can find clusters
that make sense.
But that's our approach.
Yeah, and it's funny, because
the percentile thing--
there's a sense that,
well, if we've just got
better and better percentiles.
But you're still dealing
with average and deviation.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's very clear to me
how individual learning
can be implemented
in online learning like
in the Khan Academy
or even I think Harvard
has a program called
HBX and those online courses.
But how do you think
it will be implemented
in general education?
Because most of education--
also the normative institutions
that actually give
you a document saying
you have a degree and actually
that enables you to have
a career-- don't lend
themselves as easily
to individual learning.
TODD ROSE: Yeah.
It's a great question.
So that's actually
like the thing
that keeps me up at night.
And we it's why I started the
nonprofit called the Center
for Individual Opportunity.
And we have a Beyond
Average Initiative
that's solely focused
on taking these ideas
and trying to create scalable
solutions in education.
So when I first started
writing the book and start
thinking about it, I
thought we have these ideas.
But the solutions would
be a long way off.
It would just take a long time.
But what's been really
surprising to me, especially
in the education space,
is that there are actually
all kinds of really
innovative solutions
that are already out there.
But they're on the
fringe of the system
right now, because you
still have a system that's
based on averages.
So it's hard to see the
value of these things.
But my bet is this--
so you have to rethink
some basic fundamental things
about the education system.
If it's in K through
12, you simply
can't have age-based cohorts.
You just can't.
But what we're seeing
a shift toward-- that
feels like, oh, that
we really complicated.
But you can actually
easily group people
by where they're at in their
progression on any given topic.
And we've seen
this-- funny enough,
we've seen evidence
of this for 100 years.
The San Francisco
Normal School actually
did a complete individualized
bricks and mortar
approach that was really
fantastic in the early 1900s.
But I think to do
it at scale, there's
no getting around the fact you
absolutely need the technology.
And that would be a
bad thing in the past
when the barrier to
entry for that technology
was pretty high.
But the truth is-- a good
HTML5-enabled browser
actually does
everything we need to do
this kind of deep
personalization.
So most of our focus
now is on making sure
that we don't allow
the technologies that
are being brought
into the schools
to be like walled gardens, which
is usually the business model.
Come in here.
And we'll let you inside
our beautiful thing.
And so we're really
pushing to make sure
that we have these
open environments
and open to resources that
are the utility of the system.
But I actually
think we're not that
far off, because I think
most people realize they
want personalized learning.
And my final piece, I would
say, is in higher education,
which is obviously where
I reside, the push is flat
away from fixed-time
grade-based learning,
which is kind of weird.
I have two sons.
They're both in college now.
So it's ridiculously expensive.
But I think like, wait a minute.
They're in robotics
and computer science.
And they come back
and say, well, I
took my little semester.
And this is the grade I got.
I think, wait a minute.
That's not what I'm paying for.
I'm not paying for you to go
there and say, OK, time's up.
Now, how did you compare to
the people sitting next to you.
You're there to master
things that you can then
get the job that you want.
So I think what we're
seeing, and we're
seeing this-- the higher ed
price point is just pushing us
toward this-- but toward
credentials, micro credentials,
that you can stack
and create, and
competency-based measurements.
I think that's going to
go first and pretty fast
just because of the
economic incentives.
AUDIENCE: So as we're
starting to design more
personalized learning
opportunities, or products,
or whatever.
Obviously, especially
in the beginning,
we won't be able to make every
single thing individualized.
So how do we start
to make trade-offs
of where we should put our
efforts for customization?
TODD ROSE: Yeah, that's
a really great question.
So when I think
of personalization
from this individuality
standpoint,
it really comes down to a
combination of flexibility
and adaptability.
And I think we get really
obsessed, especially
in the startup space, with
the adaptability thing, right?
So we're going to
figure out the algorithm
that we'll know
right where you're at
and will adjust things
to you, which is great.
But the flexibility
issue is actually
a pretty important one.
If you design really narrow
environments, on average,
I think in school, it's
called age appropriate.
We literally incentivize that.
Like, yay, he did it!
He made a cockpit that
fits nobody, right?
Then you create all
kinds of friction
that actually makes it harder
to do good adaptability.
And so I think
the first place is
in ensuring your designing to
the edges-- really thinking
if it's your customer base.
And I'm probably
preaching to the choir.
But you know who
your audience is.
And you know the range
of characteristics.
They're different.
There's a reason why Google
has Google Translate.
It's not to be nice, right?
It's like you've got
to get people-- you're
trying to get right good ads.
But even just that-- the ability
to deal with the language
barrier to allow people
to be in the common space
and have that conversation
is phenomenal.
So I think thinking
about the same way
with a cockpit design thinking
about designing to the edges
for characteristics that matter
and creating the flexibility.
The second piece to that is
I think from an education
standpoint, our bet is
on empowering students
with the kind of
self-knowledge to make choices
on their own behalf.
And this new science
I think has something
to say about that, right?
If I try to teach that you
can know yourself as a type--
I'm a gifted student, or
whatever-- it's just not
good enough.
It doesn't tell you enough.
But if kids know
they're jagged profiles.
They know the context
in which they thrive
and in which they
struggle-- and they
understand how to make
choices-- I think that gets us
even closer to personalization.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
that just popped in my head.
Suppose, I don't know, this
individualized learning gets
implemented and whatnot,
how do you measure
the success of such a system?
Do you use averages?
Is that OK?
I don't know.
TODD ROSE: That's a great
question to pop in your head.
So, again, I think what's
going to be so important.
And I, in my love of all
things individuality,
I often have to
stop and say, again,
there are places for averages.
So if I want to know how a
school district is doing,
actually, averages and other
parameters are really valuable.
What's funny about
knowing how well someone's
doing and performing
in these systems--
often people think, well,
if you don't compare kids
to other kids, how
would you know.
That doesn't tell us
anything, actually.
You could have a
whole class of people
who aren't doing very well.
But I'm the best
of the people that
aren't doing very well, right?
So actually most
of what we're doing
is getting toward
competency-based stuff
where we clearly define
outcomes like what is it
that they're supposed
to learn and how would
we know when they're on that
path and in their learning?
And you just keep benchmarking
them against those competency
progressions.
Don't have to know anything
about how anyone else is
doing to know that.
And by the way, I actually
think in a higher ed position,
competency-based stuff is so
much better for employers.
Like, what a fuzzy signal.
I have a diploma--
a four-year diploma,
and I got like a 3.2
or something like that.
What does that mean?
Versus, I have
these competencies.
I think it's a much
better place to be.
AUDIENCE: So Finland has a very
unorthodox education system.
They've removed all their
national certification testing.
They don't do homework.
They do a lot of unique things.
And they found that
the students score
like-- I guess the way they
assess their output has gone
really high across the world.
Do you have any insight to the
US public education system?
And is there any
trends of trying
to remove some of these
traditional systems that are
in place in the public systems?
TODD ROSE: So we've
struggled-- what's
interesting about
the US, even if we
use standardized, traditional
metrics to compare
global rankings and stuff, is
we get obsessed with ranking
ourselves on average.
Oh, on average, the
US is falling behind.
And Finland, by the way,
deserves all the credit
in the world.
They do really innovative stuff.
But what's interesting
about the US--
and I'll tell you where I
think we're going with this.
But if you
disaggregate the data,
and you just look at the
schools in which there's
10% or less poverty, which is
actually about where Finland
is in general, right?
I think the last I
remember-- we're actually
those schools which are a
substantial number of schools
are actually the
best in the world.
And then if you look at the
schools for which poverty
is 10% to 25%, we're
third in the world.
It's just that we have
schools that are literally 90%
poverty, 95% poverty.
And they score really poorly.
So first of all, I think
averages mislead us even
in how we think about
how we do as a country.
And it leads us to allocate
resources in the wrong way,
because this is
just fundamentally
about the inequitable position
of access to good resources,
right?
But what I think is
interesting is that in state
after state now, there's
an acknowledgment
by the secretaries of education
that the system just flat
out doesn't work.
It's no longer
enough just to try
to optimize an old
industrial system
and call it a win
on average, right?
In fact, the whole
model of education
can't be batch
processed anymore.
So the thing we're
all struggling
with in the public school
system is how do you
convert a system that literally
was meant to know as little as
possible about any one kid?
And it was meant to produce
standardized workers-- that
was the goal-- to one that's
more of a development model
where we need to grow talent.
So that's where
we're at right now
and where I'm actually
pretty optimistic frankly,
because we've got an economic
imperative like companies
are just flat out-- we're not
producing the talent we need.
There's a moral imperative
here around the purpose
of education.
And we now have the
technology and the science
to actually do this at scale.
So what we're really focused
on is connecting this science
to the practice
of personalization
and trying to develop
what I would call
the utilities of
the system-- things
that you want everyone to have
access to that can't really
be monetized and
making sure we're
building it in a way
that's equitable.
But I think you're going to see
some really innovative things
out of the public school
system over the next decade.
AUDIENCE: It's
illegal in Finland
to have private school systems
that basically is a business.
And they trying to make money.
So what that allows them to
do is every school is public.
And every school-- I guess
you can consider average.
But every school is
considered the same.
So you don't have areas that
have high-scoring schools where
these well-off
people may move to.
And then you develop
pockets of poverty
to address what you're saying.
And those become your
lower-scoring schools.
So every school is the same
output of education in Finland.
And I don't know how
the US could get away
from monetizing and
making school a business
with private schools.
But that's how I think how
Finland's attacked the problem.
TODD ROSE: Yeah, and
I think that what's
really important about this
is-- so Finland has absolutely
just nailed this industrial
model in an equitable way.
And if you talk to
leaders of Finland,
I think their biggest
concern is they're trapped--
it's like golden handcuffs.
They're trapped by
these rankings now.
And they're like,
no, we were trying
to not have this system that
is so captured by rankings.
But now, everyone is like,
yay, we're number one.
So don't change anything, right?
But I think that the thing that
we need to learn from Finland,
and that we have a choice to
make I think in the next five
years that these things
are going to be decided,
is in our-- capitalism
is fantastic as a method
if you realize it's
just a method, right?
It's not the value.
Otherwise, it would
just use child labor,
because it's way more efficient.
You have values to the society.
And then you let
capitalism do its work.
We're not going to
go away from having
schools be able to be private.
That's free enterprise.
But here's what we can do.
Right now we're making
decisions about the architecture
of the new digital
learning environments that
will be deployed everywhere.
It's just cheaper than
print textbooks now.
So every company is
going this direction.
So we get a once in
a lifetime chance
to define the parameters
of that system.
So one thing that
we're betting on
is we think, look,
we love startups.
But start up business
models are not about equity.
You're not going-- equity
in a different way probably.
But you're not going to say, how
do we make the decisions that
are better for everyone versus
how do we capture enough
of the market to make money?
So what we're
betting on is this--
If we go back to the
view of like-- back
in the day with browsers
when Microsoft was dominating
with Internet Explorer.
And they were trying to
monetize that, right?
And they really were winning.
And frankly folks like
Google and other places
realize, OK, you're not going
to beat Microsoft if you're
going to monetize browsers.
So what do you do?
I think you have given a
billion dollars to Mozilla
over the years to build Firefox.
And say, let's not
monetize the browser.
Let's make it open source
and make it phenomenal.
And then, look, if
Microsoft can make
something that's better
than that, then maybe
people will pay for it.
But it turns out, it's
really darned good.
And you can monetize
other things.
So I think the most
important thing
we're going to do right
now with this technology
is say, look, we want
people to make money,
but they've got to make
money on the right things.
So let's put the utilities
of the system in place,
make them free and fabulous,
and then incentivize
the right kind of outcomes.
So that's what keeps
us up at night.
How do we make sure we're
bringing this in and making
those choices that
create a foundation that
can be excellent and equitable?
DEBBIE NEWHOUSE: So thank you
so much everyone for coming.
Thank you, Todd, for
being with us at Google.
You brought us a lot of
thought-provoking ideas
and I think areas where
we can take action.
And I do recommend
reading the book.
It has a lot more examples.
And it has some that are
more closely associated
with product decisions, things
about personnel and talent
that I'll think you'll find
really intriguing and also,
some good ideas to
understand yourself
and the people in your
family better as well.
So thank you again, Todd.
TODD ROSE: Thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]